[Music]
now during our final segment we'll
choose one bff to answer three questions
about today's show
if you answer one correctly you get a
hundred dollars
you answer two questions correctly
that's two hundred dollars and if you
answer all three
it's a thousand dollars
so stick around to play along pierre and
melissa
you have been selected
hi guys ross and i are so happy to meet
you
and how are you today
how are you all right you ready to try
and conquer these answers okay
okay if you can correctly answer three
questions about
today's show the pop quiz piggy bank is
yours
but a hundred bucks a pop no matter what
are you ready yes all right
here we go you got this first question
marcus anderson cooked in the kitchen
with drew
what meat did he cook pork chops
yeah yeah so this good old pork chop
my second question what was the name of
the show
that jamilah jamil hosts
the misery index
okay for the big pop quiz piggy bank
final question
andy mcdowell was on with us she said
her hair wasn't
gray she called it
i always correct people it's not gray
it's silver
i know you can do it oh you guys
congratulate
i'm so happy for you
and thanks for paying such great
attention
that's how you do it
we love youtube here and melissa thank
you so much and thank you to you at home
and our beautiful vfss bms are joining
us today
oh i'm so happy
and i can't talk i'm so excited thank
you so much have a wonderful rest of
your day